I'm going to help a complete stranger
build a $55 per year business in 90 days
step-by-step and at the end of the 90
days we're going to check in and show
you exactly what happened. This is Joey.
Enjoy. Joey, what's up?
All right, tell me about the business.
>> Yes. Um so my name is Joey Goon. My
business is Utopia Experience. We are an
event planning company out of St. Louis,
Missouri.
>> [screaming]
>> So last year the average deal size for
event planning was 34,000. This year uh
trailing 12 months is 44,000. Audio
visual average uh spend is between 20
and 150k per event. Video production is
more of a pass-through to just make it
easy for clients.
>> Got it. Okay. What's holding you back
right now?
>> I'm just not really sure what the
strategy is that we should pursue when
it comes to the acquisition channel. I'm
at an inflection point in my business
where I know if I don't do this, we are
going to take massive steps backwards.
We need the strategy to scale to the
next level and that's why I'm here.
>> So why do you think this can scale?
>> That's a great question.
>> [laughter]
>> I just I'm I'm just like in awe. I'm I
love you so much.
>> It's mutual, man.
>> Um
why do I think this can scale? So before
I came here, I actually flew here from
my sister's wedding in Mexico. I asked
100 people on that trip with us, it's
like the entire wedding party, what's
one thing in your life that you could
never have enough of? And I thought I'd
get some silly answers cuz people are
drunk doing whatever in the pool and I
thought I was going to get sex or money
and I got some of that, but mostly what
people told me was some version
of connection, community, tribe, family,
belonging.
>> Yeah.
>> And that's the industry that we're in.
So our industry, what we're selling is
fundamentally what people need. It is a
human need. It's wired into our primal
DNA and so that's why I think it could
scale. And the market cap on events
right now is 1.5 trillion. It's
projected to hit 3.5 trillion by 2033.
>> Amazing.
>> So those numbers
>> Yeah. Big.
>> back up our industry. I'm so convicted
on my quest that I'm going to persevere.
I've been resilient since I was a
9-year-old kid.
I know this business is going to grow
with your help. I'm ready to scale it.
>> Sweet. Walk me through how your pricing
process works because it's very it's
very like make-believe, right? Yeah, so
yeah, so yeah, yeah.
And since you have a margin issue, I
think it's a margin issue, how does
how do these numbers [clears throat] get
pulled out of thin air? Cuz right now it
sounds like they just say we want X, Y,
and Z and then you create some line
items and then make up numbers on those
line items and then come up with a
number at the bottom and then send it to
them. Like I come to you and I say I'm
doing an acquisition.com event, right?
We're going to do a a thousand-person
event here in Vegas and we want full AV
and some on-site support. What go like
when you hear that, what actually goes
through your head?
>> What's included in every package is a
$15,000 or or overall retainer to retain
our services. So that's the first thing.
>> Like a one-time upfront fee that gets
added on to the other make-believe
prices.
>> Exactly.
>> Got it. Okay. [snorts]
>> Yeah. And then after that, it's you
know, sponsor management. That's about
15k. Then there's vendor management.
Vendor management is like managing all
the contractors. So it's
the photo booth, video production team,
all all of those elements that that you
know, sort of come into the event. It's
the venue procurement strategy. So if
you guys if you're taking your team to
some other place outside of Vegas, you
need a hotel. Which hotel are you going
to work with? How are you going to get
people to and from the airport?
>> Audio bill for the logistics of managing
that as well if it's part of the scope
of work or whatever.
>> Right. That's 7,500.
>> Is there anything about headcount?
>> That's the thing. So we learned a
lesson, we put the guardrails up, and so
now we're actually deploying like tiered
structures where if you have over a
certain number of attendees or over a
certain amount of vendors or sponsors,
then there's a tier that where you pay
more based on the number of people that
you have.
>> Got it. Okay. I think I know what to do.
Do do to hop on the side?
>> Sure.
>> [music]
>> So, um,
there's a dimension issue for sure, but
I think that part of it is because
you're mispriced. And so, the pricing
has to do with the offer, and so we kind
of have to start with the offer and then
fix price and then go sales motion and
then go demand increase.
Does that make sense?
>> Got it.
>> Okay, we've got to fix the thing we're
selling. Once we fix the thing we're
selling, we'll fix how we're selling it.
And then,
uh, if we're selling it well, we can
price it the way we want to price it.
Okay.
So,
>> Can't believe I'm sitting next to you
right now.
>> [laughter]
>> It's mutual.
Um,
okay. So, the first thing that has to
happen is you have to cost out what true
costs are for
different levels of delivery.
And then, whenever you have that price,
I want you to 5 or 10x that cost.
And then that's what your price is.
>> Okay.
>> And so, you'll probably have to create,
um, like a dynamic sheet which you could
either code with AI really easily or
just have like an if-then type Excel
sheet. Either way would work. But as
you're going through it with a a
customer, it should basically pop out
what that price for that thing's going
to be and it's all dynamic.
So, I have head count of the event.
And then from there, we're going to have
our, uh,
uh, variable costs, which are what are
the costs that scale
with head count. So, we have
>> vendors.
>> Yeah, exactly. So, these are these are
the costs that scale with this and are
going to be proportional. And then we're
going to have fixed costs,
which is going to be Amber can only
She's It's 1/4 of Amber. So, it's like,
"Great, that's going to be 15k is 1/4 of
Amber cuz she can only handle four." And
then, what other fixed costs do we have
that are probably going to be more, uh,
fixed payroll stuff versus kind of the
other costs that are associated that are
going to be more like the AV related or
whatever.
>> Got it. Does that track?
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> Okay. So, once you have this, it's like,
you're going to have a sheet that has a
cost number that comes to the bottom.
You're not going to show that to them.
Um, and then at that point, you know
that your range is going to be 5 to 10x
this number.
And that to me would be like
how rich is the person I'm talking to.
I'm I'm like I'm just being real. Like
bigger company, like if you if you if
you get if you get lawn care in one of
the top 10 zip codes in the United
States and you have the exact same
amount of grass and you have it in a
really poor part of the United States,
the price difference between that lawn
care as somebody who knows
>> For sure it's
>> It's two to three x difference and I
just call it a zip code tax, right? This
is the privilege I get to have is to pay
more for the exact same thing.
>> I love that. Zip code tax.
>> Can I just say to all the future clients
out there that you're going to pay
you're going to make it's going to be a
great price. Whatever you pay is going
[laughter] to be, you know,
>> You're fine.
Um, at the end of the day, everyone else
is doing this too. They're just not
being organized about it. Um,
so that's number one is that we need to
have standardized pricing so that you
can actually get your sales guys to be
able to quote without having this super
long delay in the process and so at the
end of the year you're not like how much
money do we make? We should know exactly
how much money we're making on every
event.
>> Sure.
This yeah, this this seems like a
programmable AI thing that can be done
in a couple hours.
>> Yes. So hey, this is Al from the future.
Um, I've already given Joey his verdict,
but I think what's more interesting for
you, independent of what that verdict
is, what actually happened when he
implemented what I told him to do.
>> So
what we did was we built, per your
recommendation, a pricing module so that
our team can accurately quote on our
discovery calls.
And in the past, we would send a
proposal via email and people would
email back and say like either feels
like a lot or my needs have changed and
we
like we weren't able to handle those
things via email. Now we're handling it
live during the call, um, which is just
like it's been more consultative and our
clients, prospects are really
appreciating that because they're able
to surface like any objections if we can
handle live on the call. And if they
have like additional things that they
need from us, we're able to add those
into scope and give them a real-time
like here's how that impacts your
overall investment with us, which they
they love and and they appreciate.
>> All right. I I have very few rules of
law, but a rule of sales is never
present an invoice via email.
It should always be over the phone
because they're going to have questions,
and you want to be the person who can
answer those questions, aka resolve
their concerns, and then get them to
buy. Now, to make this kind of offer
better, this gives us our cost basis. Um
what I want to do is add um basically a
price lock guarantee,
which is like
as long as you don't change anything
about this, this is going to be the
price.
And uh we give a, you know, 10% discount
um if you prepay it all ahead.
>> Mhm.
>> That way you can pull cash forward. Cuz
right now I'm sure you're getting paid
some now, some in the middle, some at
the end, or something like that. Does
that sound true?
>> So yeah, and something that um
that I'm going through is I've never
been in through a lawsuit.
>> Mhm.
>> Um suing a client right now who didn't
pay us, and now we're having to hunt
down the money, and uh
>> Do they have money?
>> No, they just filed for bankruptcy.
>> point in suing.
>> Yeah, voluntary bankruptcy.
>> point in suing. Yeah. Just save your
save your dollars, call it a cost of
business.
>> Yeah, that's fair.
>> Yeah. Just let me let me save you some
time. Let me save you some money and
some headache. It's not you're not going
to get the money, so there's no point.
>> Navigating that, so like getting it all
up front
>> Yeah.
>> uh helps us avoid having to chase it
later.
>> Yeah.
>> Um there's also the value of money
today. If you if you have a met a year
from now, you just stuck that money into
a bond or whatever, you know what I
mean? Or the the stock market, well,
stock market's probably not the best way
to put it, but uh something that's, you
know,
a fixed income asset, you'd be able to
make make the money back, but you also
get the value of speed of money today,
and most businesses have higher returns
on capital than the stock market does,
especially small businesses. And so
you're going to get better returns on
that, so it makes sense to at least give
10 or 20% to pull it up. Now, we've
already built this padding in, so we're
fine.
>> Yeah.
>> Now,
I want to also create uh a separate
opportunity, which is on the events that
are B2B. Now, there's not going to be a
lot of them, but the ones where the
audience is the customer, I want to have
a separate approach to it. So this is
our standard way of billing.
If someone is B2B,
they're basically throwing an event for
you.
Okay?
>> Not actually, but like they have uh uh
a
You have to take
Not that you wouldn't take extra care
with a normal event, but if there's ever
been a time to blow people's socks off
and have an amazingly run event, this
would be the time to do it.
>> Sure.
>> Because everybody in the audience is a
potential customer.
>> It's the franchisor associations where
you've got 1,500 of them in in the
audience that are all doing conferences.
>> Love it. So, with these people, it's
like number one is or rather A,
um I would say uh we want to get the
booth for ourselves in there because
they're going to have, you know, a
booth. Number two is you want to have
the opportunity to some sort of speaking
um at the event.
And it can be like a 15-minute slot. It
doesn't have to be a big thing. It's
just like, "Hey, if you guys have been
loving this event, um you know,
uh we're uh we're Utopia, you know, we
uh we put this whole thing on and we do
this all the time for people like you.
Um and so, you put a little bit of
razzle-dazzle of like this is what makes
shitty events, this is what makes great
events.
Um and say, "Hey, if you want these
slides so you can give them to your your
event planner,
um just QR code on the screen and I'll
I'll send them to you so you can just
actually come into this is like I
probably think it was like uh 20
mistakes that uh people who are buying
event planning make. And so, I would
just go through all of the mistakes that
people make and with each of them proof
of one person underneath of them saying
that you're got awesome at that thing.
And say, "Hey, if you want the slides,
go grab them." Um
but the main sex appeal is that after
they kind of opt in to grab them, the
opt-in says, "Do you run events? Like,
do you host events and how many per
year?" And then that way that just
becomes a lead list for you. So, you're
not pitching, it's just like, "Hey, the
the CTA is, do you want the slides?"
which makes it much easier for you to do
for the the the customer. Now, when you
have those B2B conferences,
I would do whatever it took to to get
those ones because it's basically them
fronting all the cost of getting 500 or
1,000 of your ICP in the stadium. It's
like if you can't close 10% of that
room, then there's other issues, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Even if you close 1% of the room, you
get 15, it'd be a 50% increase in your
in your business. If you just from one
of it, right? And you do more than that
per year.
>> Yeah.
>> So, that's why I see this is super
material. Like you should be very
willing to like we have this nice high
anchor so that we can say, oh, well, you
know, I just quoted you 90,
um
but if five sponsors, right? Do you have
any issues with having a sixth? I'll pay
you for the booth. I'll pay it you your
sponsor fees 5,000 a booth. I'll pay you
5,000. It's at 95 now. How's that? Oh,
great. Right? So, it's like we can just
start chipping away at it. And if you'll
let me just do an intermission, I'm
talking 10 minutes, I'll just talk about
how events work. I'm sure we can see we
can frame it as value additive. I'll
knock another 5,000 off, right?
>> Let's start calling these different
associations.
>> And so, the last one is just uh one list
email.
So, basically just say, "Hey, I don't
want to like get your email list. That's
that's your own thing. But if after the
event I can say, 'Hey, if you had a
great time at the event,' if I can just
say like basically solicit them and then
I'll happily pay you a fee on anybody
who decides to book through us and that
can further uh bring this number down.
And I'd say in typically we're going to
get, you know, 1% of people."
>> Sure.
Alex, you also encouraged me to engage
with our ICP and you said sponsor an
event which we did here.
Cost $15,000 to sponsor a booth at that
event. We had a line the entire time and
we're going to end up closing a $500,000
piece of business um within the next
week as a result of going and sponsoring
and spending 15K. Like I'll pay 15K to
make 500 all day long.
>> Well, it looks like it paid for itself.
Um
yeah, I mean it I mean he did the he did
the stuff and then he got the outcome.
And so, you know, if you have 200%
pipeline, um
then you have a 3x sitting in the
business and he found a channel that is
getting him, I don't know what 15k to
50,500,000 is, but high
return on spend, and so uh
that's how it works. Do more of, you
know, if a little bit works, more is
usually better. And so it's just
figuring out how to do more in an
efficient way uh given constrained
resources. And he's doing it. This is
kind of the the um
offer pieces, and then this can
hopefully fix pricing and also the
instant quote issue that you have.
Okay. Now, the second part is sales
motion.
So,
you're converting 10 times more than
your sales team, which is a problem.
Right?
>> [gasps]
>> Because you're doing like if you work
leads part-time, you were getting more
than two guys full-time, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, it just means you're doing
things they're not doing.
So, we just have to figure out what
those things are. So, have you audited
any of their DM conversations
um that they're having?
>> Um I've had one meeting with my sales
team. I have a follow-up, one meeting
just on this specifically. I have a
follow-up meeting with them next week to
just audit all of their communication
and just figure out like, great, like
don't say that, say this.
>> Yeah. So, what I want you to do is
basically as soon as you kick off
because the
the issue that you have is you're
obviously demand constrained. Um I don't
want to forget this one thing. Um
Okay, back to this. Um so,
instead of weekly like you should be
meeting with them every single day to
drive and then do end of day. Because
right now this like you need to drive
this. Like first thing in the morning,
what's your plan? How many touch points
you're going to do?
Um great, like walk me through the the
leads that you're working. What kind of
prep have you done for those those calls
and those reach outs so you can
personalize them? Um and then end of
day, how did the conversations go? Where
are we at with pipeline? Like we need to
drive this.
>> Okay.
>> From a role-playing perspective, the way
that like uh don't do this, do that,
you have to then give them the
opportunity to try in front of you. Now,
part of this is going to be the actual
sales, but right now are they just
mostly setting for you to close or they
setting for themselves to close?
>> Yeah, they're they're kind of they're
end-to-end.
>> Yeah. Um
>> Do I need to restructure that?
>> I'd rather have them just set
appointments for you because you don't
your sales volume is like two a week,
right? It's not It's not a huge or not
one a week. Um
if you had two guys just setting
appointments for you, the likelihood
that you'll close them is significantly
higher. And you're also the business
owner and you can kind of flex on some
of these things a little bit better.
I would rather you do that because
what you're closing 40% of sales, right?
That you talk to?
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, if you have four appointments a
week, like that's not going to really
change anything. But all of a sudden,
you double your business. If you have
eight appointments a week, you quadruple
your business.
So, and that's still not a lot of like
that's not a lot of work.
>> So, just have them be like SDRs, BDRs.
>> Mhm.
>> Book in my calendar completely full.
>> still give them a commission on the on
the on the thing that they bring in. But
you're like, "Listen, you'll make more
money if I'm selling than you are." So,
like do this for now. And then I think
that'll allow you to stay closer to it
so that you can document the process
better and your feedback loops will be
faster cuz you're like, "Hey, I got
nothing on my calendar today. What the
hell's going on?"
In a nice way.
>> Sure.
>> Right?
Does that feel okay?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Uh weekly I go deep with one of
them or not one of them, with each of
them one-on-one.
Um the way that we structure these is
basically you go personal.
You say, "Hey, how you doing? Hey, if
you're you know, your mom just died,
then like let's talk about that. Make
sure you're good cuz you're not thinking
about your KPIs or quotas if you just
got dumped or whatever."
Um the next is assuming they don't have
any like personal calamities, we say,
"Okay, we we focus on short-term stuff.
You're messing this up in the in in the
intro. You're messing this up in the in
this part of the scripting."
If they're crushing their KPIs, say,
"Hey, long-term, what are your goals
here? Why don't we Why don't we you
shadow some of my sales calls so that
you can maybe pick up some of this other
stuff." It's basically giving them
growth opportunities. But that's the the
the progression that we do with uh
weekly one-on-ones and in here, it's all
role playing. Like
forever. Just like you train sales to
role play.
>> Yeah.
>> Cuz you have to get you have to get them
to try and so that you can correct them
and have more feedback loops. Just think
how many feedback loops do I have? These
people it's the only way they learn.
Just like saying it at them will do
literally nothing.
>> What's what's my you know, my brother
and I have been consuming your content
for 5 years, him longer than me.
>> Yeah.
>> I had a call with my brother last week
and he's like, "The Hormozi in me is
telling you that we're not doing You're
not doing this." So, I started booking
daily check-ins with my
>> Oh, good. Good. I've restructured how
the sales team is engaging at Utopia.
And so, instead of doing the full cycle
end to end, their job now, at least in
the spirit of like this 90-day sprint,
they're prospecting and they're booking
discovery calls. That is it. But, Alex,
you said, "Joey, once you bring on
proficient competent sales reps
who will get it, you're not going to 2x,
you're going to like 5 to 10x." And I'm
really seeing that now and that we have
200% more volume in our pipeline just in
the discovery calls that are getting
booked, which is huge for us.
>> It's nice when things work as
advertised.
Now, I want to give you something that I
think is going to be super, super
high-leverage,
which is um an idea that I had um while
you were talking, which is when you open
up the call,
after you say, "Hey, how's it going?"
whatever,
um and you set the agenda for the call,
>> Yeah.
>> what's the first question you ask them?
>> Why'd you book this call today? Why not
6 months from now? Why not 6 months ago?
>> Okay. So, you're clarifying where
they're there, you're on the C part.
What I What I want to do There's one
question I want to ask in the earlier
part of the process, which is how many
events per year you do? Because I want
automatically, as soon as they can say,
"Well, we do three events a year." Now,
I just took our average ticket from
80k and made it 240k because now I'm
trying to bid for all three.
>> Yeah.
>> And then what we can do is say, "Hey,
why don't we do all Like, I'll commit to
all three for you. We'll do the first
one, and assuming the first one goes
great,
we'll book the other two at the same
rate. That way we can start like trying
to increase average ticket and then get
into these kind of like very recurring
relationships." Do you like that
question cuz I think that will have a
very big effect. I just want to make
sure that that gets added into the
script.
>> Okay. Inspired by your question, like,
"Hey, how many events is your
organization doing every year?" So, we
started asking prospects that. They love
the idea of being able to do that and to
promote next year at this year's event.
And of course it's a win for them cuz
they can do that they can sell
sponsorships today for tomorrow. That's
been a major win for us because now
we've just converted a one year client
into a three year client.
>> Tripling LTV by just getting them to buy
more of the thing they just bought tends
to always work. Doesn't always triple
LTV, but getting people to offering them
to buy more of what they just bought
almost always does. And one more thing
we got to add.
So
in your existing sales process just the
way you were doing it you'd reach out to
them, you'd qualify the lead, and then
you'd set appointment, correct?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
Before they and on that appointment you
then basically collect all this
information and then you'd say, "Let me
get back to you." And then you'd set a
follow-up appointment and then you would
try and close them on the next call,
correct?
>> Yeah, go through the proposal with them
live cuz then you can actually kind of
work through those questions and and
handle the objections.
>> Yes.
So um
I want you to add a video sales letter
before the call.
>> Okay.
I just recorded it.
>> So before you like before you ever talk
to a customer you should have a video
sales letter. Now if you have two
conversations there's two VSLs.
>> You said this happens before the call?
>> Mhm.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. And when someone hops on the call
if they have like the first question Now
inside of the VSL um I can walk you
through how to structure it but if you
already did it then we can leave it. I
like having a little nugget in there
which is having one CTA that's like hey
by the way text me
your head count.
Text me the date of the event that you
want to do. Text me the week or text me
the season. Whatever it is. We just want
to have something so we have some
indication they actually watched it. And
then also engages them with us. So
that's going to increase the likelihood
of the show. But beyond that when you
start the call
um
you'll find out quickly like did you did
you watch the video? If the answer is
yes, great. If the answer is no, then we
say, "Hey, no worries. Um this will save
us like 30 minutes on the call. 7
minutes. Um play this now. I'm going to
grab a cup of coffee. You want a cup of
coffee? Haha it's Zoom. Huh? Okay.
Uh and I'll be right back. And so then
they watch it and then that way they're
fresh and primed and the whole
conversation has already been framed and
you've been edified and all that kind of
jazz.
>> Yeah.
>> Cuz this is also what helps you scale
sales once it once you stop being the
person selling
because we want to do as much of the
lifting as we can for the sales people
including you because what this will do
is it will also shorten the amount of
calls you have to have. So if you're
currently doing two, if we do a VSL and
then we can do an instant quote, we
might be able to
change to a one call close.
>> Got it.
>> And even worst case scenario, even if
you like having the two call which I'm
not against two calls at certain price
points, sometimes it just people just
want to like it it gives the
approximation of knowing someone. Um we
can still have our instant quote and
then rather than saying let's meet in
five days, you can say
I'll have this to you by
what time tomorrow works best for you?
I'll work on this until until then cuz
there's also a speed element of like if
it takes you a week to get me a quote,
I'm like man, how long is it like is
this what it's going to be like working
with these people? If it's like this is
priority for me, we'll get this done,
you know, I'll get this done by the day.
And how's first thing tomorrow morning?
It's like that speed I can almost
guarantee you will increase close rates.
>> Cool.
>> Got it.
>> Okay. Ah, this is another little a
little nugget. So after the events that
you hold, what happens? So the event's
done, now what?
>> Within
usually within two days of landing back
in St. Louis, we send a follow-up email
to the hosts. We get them on an event
debrief call. That's where we're going
through what worked, what do we want to
see improved and when's the event the
event date for next year? Let's get it
booked.
>> Okay, love that. Just add a VSL
beforehand.
>> Really?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> conversation you have with the customer
frame it.
>> Okay.
>> And so for here it's like
>> Different different VSL? [clears throat]
>> It'll be same the structure will be the
same. You want different examples and
the
the objections are going to be the ones
that happen after someone has an event
and is thinking about booking the next
one not before they book their first
event. So the objections will be
different.
>> Okay.
>> So they'll be like is it going to be the
same price? We'll say well it depends on
like so you're just going to go through
with the FAQs normally would be and then
just answer them ahead of time before
the call.
And that way you can spend the whole
call actually closing rather than just
like transferring information and like
yapping at them.
>> Got it.
>> But that'll frame the call so that
basically it's like
um
So, you know, you just went through your
first event with us. Um hopefully it was
amazing. Don't worry, we're going to go
through the They go like everything like
we Perfection is our standard, and so
nothing's ever perfect, and we always
want to get better, and that's how we've
continued to grow as a company. Um
That being said, there's some questions
that people have, which is like uh
billing logistics, uh what happens with
their other future events, uh when am I
going to get my my video stuff like all
the questions that people normally have.
Um and then included in that would be,
"Okay, how does How does working with
like basically Where do we go from here?
What's the next step?" And I say, "So,
um
what we're going to do on the call is
also just book, figure out what the next
event is, so that we can get even more
advanced prep, because basically the
more prep we have, the better the event
is."
And so, right. And so, I would just say
like, "So, I can tell you that even if
there were somebody who is better than
us at this, which there aren't any, of
course,
if you book with us now, we will be
better than somebody who is better than
us. And so, you get better value by
booking now."
>> Great frame.
>> Yeah. Damage your mission.
>> Also, our VSLs are gold. So, we have a
top of the funnel VSL, which is like,
"Here's the avatar, here's the pain,
here's the, you know, sort of the
threshold to work with us."
And now people are getting on the calls
and they're like, "Oh my gosh, it's like
you knew me." And that's been really
validating for our team to finally be
like, you know, we're going 10 mi deep
and an inch wide, where in the past we
thought in order to scale we had to go
10 mi wide, and it's just not that way.
Like now that we've like narrow-casted
and focused in on this particular
avatar, it's amazing that like nine out
of 10 prospects are experiencing the
exact same pain. Now we can speak to
that, we've systematized it, and it's
much more scalable.
>> When you get clear on the avatar, you
can systematize and templatize the
solution, which allows you to sell for
higher margins and have more operational
scale, which he is now experiencing. You
also will reduce CAC because your
messaging is now aligned with that
avatar. So, he's probably selling better
people for less than he was before and
making more margin.
>> We We now have a bottom of the funnel
VSL. And the bottom of the funnel VSL is
for your busy CEO who or CFO who's
ultimately making the decision, but is
maybe not going to join the call.
Um that is been something that has
helped us get some deals across the
line.
>> Love that. So, now we can talk about the
Like what is the order of operations?
Does that work?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So,
number one,
we need to we need to create the call
like the auto auto
quote
generator.
Which shouldn't take you that long to
build. But you just have to think
through what are the costs, what are the
variables, what are the what are the
fixed costs, and then how is it depend
by head count? Great. Now we have our we
have our at least our cost basis. And
then that gives us our range for our
pricing. Right?
Uh second, uh you'll add in kind of the
referral
/promotion incentives
to
this so that you can put your discounts
in so that you can get you can basically
solicit more business from them. That's
the list and the speaking and
the survey close of like, "Hey, get my
slides and then you can sort from there
to get new leads."
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
>> Got it.
>> Third element is we need to do DLE
sales training, implement VSLs
times three because you have three kind
of touch points. You have call one, call
two, and then post call.
Right?
We have to increase our
uh
outreach.
Which is going to be first, they're
going to start every day by maxing out
the platform limits, which means they
should be doing exactly what you were
doing when you were doing outreach. They
should just clone exactly what you're
doing. If they're not doing that, then
like either they're the wrong people or
you're not good at training.
Um then we want to do an AI scrape
of the contacts
to get
numbers.
And then we want to feed that into a
dialer.
And there's a ton of different dialer
softwares um out there
that you can use.
>> What what would you do with the dialer?
You're having it call the
>> We want to call the we just want to you
want to hit it from as many channels as
you can. And you're going to have more
Like you will be limited by this more
than you'll be limited by this. And so
the call these like the highest
likelihood responses because it's
warmer, etc.
Um but these are where you're going to
be able to get a lot of volume.
>> Got it. And for max platform, you're
talking about something like LinkedIn.
Like as many DMs as you can possibly
send on the platform. Because
>> Exactly.
>> Got it. So you think is Facebook a solid
channel that you think we should pursue
or not?
>> LinkedIn would probably I would stick
with LinkedIn. You've already done that
there. You already have a proven
process. They're not following it, but
you have a proven process. So it's like
how do we just do more of that for now?
Cuz I know you have all these different
acquisition channels and my whole focus
here was like how do we get really
narrow on the one that like you have the
best LTV CAC on LinkedIn.
So let's do that. And let's do way more
of it. You already hired two guys. So
it's like we should need to get them
on ramps. And you need to do that with
lots of training and making sure that
they are motivated.
>> Sure.
>> That's basically it. And if you say this
is what we're doing twice a day every
day, I promise you the productivity of
the team's going to go up. And since
it's the constraint, it's a good use of
your time.
The
piece here is this pricing generator.
We should be at 5 to 10x our costs for
the product. Now obviously that's your
going to be your estimate. Your Like we
have to have five is the minimum because
it might go over, right? Like you don't
know. Um but the price lock says that we
will charge this as long as you don't
change anything.
If you change something,
then we might have to readjust it. And
then we'll true up at the end.
>> Okay.
>> Now, the higher you go in here, the more
you can say
as long as you're not changing the head
count by more than 20% between now and
then or we have to change venues or
anything like that, um this will be the
cost no matter what. So you can use that
as a Like if I were selling this,
I would say something like So there's
two ways that this pricing works. So one
way is you get nickel and dimed, the
other is that we just pick a price
that's within your budget, and then as
long as you don't do anything crazy,
that's what the price is going to be.
Which one would you rather do?
Right. They're like just tell me the
just tell me the price it's going to be.
It's like great. Boom boom. And then we
factor in all of the the fudge factor.
And so it's like to be clear, you're not
going to change your venue, and you're
not going to change your headcount more
than 20%. We agreed on that? Okay. And
like you're not going to all of a sudden
say like I want AV. Like these are the
services that you're going to get. I'll
I'll give you fudge factor on headcount
up to 20, and then you can't change the
and you can't change the date, right? So
you can't change the date, can't change
the venue, and then that way it you
don't it confines the scope. If they
break that, which they might, then you
have a different conversation. And I
don't think I would try and jab people.
I just feel like listen, it's going to
cost me 30% more to do this. But if
they're already making the decision that
they need to do that, then they've
decided that it's worth it. So then if
it's worth it, then it's worth paying
you. Yeah. Does that all make sense?
>> It does.
>> Okay.
>> Would you also add in a, you know, like
a multi-year kind of agreement?
>> I mean, my goal of asking
how many events are you doing is so that
I can seed off the fact that okay, most
people who are in your position you're
doing three events a year,
um and they're are all three events
going to be like this? Great, I can give
you a better rate if we do all three
than if we just do one. And so it's like
we'll give you a 10% Again, it's like I
like this big anchor so that I can say
I'll give you 10% off uh on all three,
but we're already way above your current
price.
>> Sure.
>> Uh I'll give you 10% off on all three
um if you commit to doing all three with
us now. And if for some reason you want
to break it because you think we suck,
which is totally fine, just pay the
difference on on on what you would have
owed us. So it gives a little bit of a
stick.
>> Heard.
>> Right? And so if that 10% off is uh and
then it's like we'll give you another
10% off if you prepay all three. Some
people in that that may sound crazy to
you, but a lot of departments and
businesses work on annual budgets. And
so it's like listen, it's about to be
tax season, and you want to get this off
your books now because we have one event
now and two next year.
Prepay for the event now, and that way
you can you know have you don't have to
pay taxes on it.
>> Mhm.
>> Is that right?
>> Yeah. That all works super well Q4.
>> Got it.
>> No Well, we do like cuz a lot of
people they're you know, they're looking
at their Q1 Q2, sometimes you know,
depending how last minute they are,
right? So Q3 Q4 you'll be getting the
events for you know, Q1 Q2, maybe Q3.
And so it's like get the cash off your
books, pay your taxes down, you get a
discount and you don't have to pay
taxes. It's a double it's a double
whammy. Like, why not do it?
>> Yeah.
>> Joe?
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
Um
and you had one question about the fact
like you speaking at events,
right? Like you speak at these events.
>> Mhm.
>> Um I think you should speak at as many
events as your family life uh that you
feel comfortable doing. Because you
being on stage will further edify you so
that your LinkedIn responses go up,
you'll get more inbounds, and then
obviously at the events themselves
uh you're getting leads. So it's like
it's a triple dev. And so
to the degree that you can, I would
encourage you to do it.
>> Okay.
>> So if that means
>> me being the bottleneck and I can only
be on so many sta- I mean, you the
hourly rate I think was like 1250 per
hour.
>> That's because you didn't have a really
good offer in the conversion process.
But at a B2B event, if you have a
500-person audience, there's no world
where you shouldn't be able to get 50
people or 100 people to opt in for your
thing, and then of those maybe 10 or 20%
are going to be qualified leads for you.
Like that's huge.
>> Yeah.
>> That And so you should be able to make
significantly more than $500 an hour.
So I would encourage you um
to speak at B2B but using a survey close
as your primary method.
But fundamentally, business as it
currently stands works fine. It's not
nearly as profitable as it needs to be,
which means that we have to understand
our cost better and price appropriately
in order to have more profit. In order
to solve our uh demand constraint, what
we're doing is we're getting more people
from our existing uh events that we're
doing.
>> Mhm.
>> We're training our sales team to be more
effective. We're increasing their
effectiveness with VSLs. We're
increasing the overarching volume that
they're doing in terms of outreach. And
then you're also speaking. And this is
giving you like a turbo bomb approach of
like this is the constraint is demand,
and we did have a pricing issue cuz we
don't want to jam more demand through
something that's thin margins. So let's
fix the margins of the offer, and then
jam as much demand as we can.
>> I love it.
>> That feel clear?
>> It does, yeah. I'm I'm processing.
>> Okay, yeah. I know it's probably a lot.
>> A lot of information and also an
incredible road map that is that is like
very followable.
>> Good.
>> So, I appreciate you.
>> Appreciate you, man. We're going to do
some scaling road map.
Where are to us? All right, how what's
your head count?
>> We have 30 total, 12 full-time.
>> Okay, so you're here. So, if we're
looking at what we're doing with sales,
so we need to install sales training
system, individual coaching, and a team
cadence.
We're optimizing. Right? Now, the ad
assembly process is typically if we have
a a paid side, but for you, the idea is
like uh
we're doing these events as kind of like
your like that's the thought leadership
side of this, but a lot of the um other
stuff is happening through the sales
team with increasing our outreach,
right? From a product perspective, um
incremental product improvement across
both products. So, because of the
customization of how you are going to
break down your costs, you'll be able to
get laser focused on each component of
your offer, and that's really what the
kind of product improvement at this
level is. Now, creating customer cu-
segmentation. So, this is like what we
need to do is in time, probably like a
year from now, you'll start looking and
say, "Hey, we did 100 events this year,
and what's crazy is that uh 25 of those
events were 75% of our profit." And
we're like, "Okay, so that's the
customer segment that's actually driving
the most profit for us.
How do we retool our messaging and our
marketing and the examples that we use
in our VSLs and our scripting in order
to attract more of those people? Because
then at that point we could do the exact
volume as we currently did, make four
times the money if we just only sold
those those customers. And then that's
the process of getting really narrow so
that you can then boom."
>> Sure.
>> Cool.
Um
So, by the way, if you want to know have
your own scaling road map, which has a
90-minute video. Have you gone through
this?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Pretty good, right?
>> It's really good. Yeah.
>> Um I made this as something that was
supposed to be a paid quality, and then
I was like, I should just make it for
free, so I gave it away. And so, if
you're a business owner, you're like,
"Where am I on this road map?" Um just
fill it out and it'll tell you in a lot
more detail than 30 seconds
uh where you're at and what you need to
do to get to the next level.
And the link's somewhere around here.
>> [laughter]
>> I get all these like as an entrepreneur,
we have like so many ideas and we want
to execute all the ideas and you've made
it so simple to be like, "No, just do
these three things." And that
oversimplification
has created, ironically, the most amount
of upside and the most amount of scale
that like
I never even thought I would see in our
business, let alone see it
today. And so, for that, I just I thank
you so much.
I've been struggling, banging my head
against the wall for so many years
trying to fix this problem and the
amount and the the level of momentum in
our business right now is just wild. I
am so grateful for your recommendations.
They are working and man, I'm looking
forward to winning this competition.
>> Um
yeah, we're really limited as
entrepreneurs in terms of the amount of
things we can do and a lot of things
can't work, but none of them will work
if you try to do them all. And so, we
just have to look for what things make
the most money and then ruthlessly
eliminate everything that is not those
things.
And he did that and he's
and he's seeing what happens.
And so, usually most people think their
business is is far more [music] limited
than it really is um and it's limited
because they're trying to do too much
rather than too little.
And so, [music]
it's like how do you how do you
reconcile do more and do less? It's
really that you do more of fewer.
>> My mom started this business and um
unfortunately, mom lost her battle with
cancer in 2013 and she's no longer with
us. Continuing the legacy for me means
everything. I do it because there are
people in the company that are counting
on me to show up. My family is counting
on us because my wife left her corporate
job. My dad left his as well and all
three of us are in the company together.
My wife and I now have a three-year-old
daughter whom at someday if she wants to
take over, we would love to transfer the
baton to her in the same way that my mom
passed the baton on to me.
>> And let's do [music] the verdicts.
>> [music]
>> Okay. So, uh within the context of this
competition, we've got scale it 90 days
uh who can scale the most and win
$100,000 and qualify for that or you
kind of have to do some work and nail it
first. I think that not having a defined
acquisition process is has been
something that's obviously limited the
business.
Um so, that definitely gives me a little
bit of pause on the whether or not
you'll be able to scale and then
obviously win. I want you to be in a in
a position where you could win
um if we were going to do it.
But, you
do have two sales guys that are
underutilized right now.
And if all you do
>> [music]
>> is just train with them daily and get
them to do exactly what you were doing
and just switch the offer to something
that can be significantly more valuable,
I think that you have some of the most
potential at actually winning. And so,
for that reason, we're scaling.
>> Cool.
>> Let's go.
>> [laughter]
>> All right. So, you got 90 days to grow
as much as you can. I think that if you
focus on just those two things, it's
like just get those two sales guys
productive, which means that you're
going to be in the trenches with them,
and just get that offer generator so
that your pricing is right. I think
you're going to get significantly higher
prices. I think you're going to get more
people saying yes. Have those people set
for you. And I think like I think you
have the potential to go from like one
deal a week to two or three deals. And
at not just 60, but like 70, 80, 100.
And I think that's where it all of a
sudden it's like holy we're at a
300, 400,000 a month run rate, and that
can happen very fast if we just get
those two things right.
>> Thank you.
>> I'll see you in 90 days at Iron Man.
>> You got [laughter] it.
>> Appreciate you, man.
>> Thanks, Alex. Appreciate
>> Best of luck.
>> I'm profoundly overwhelmed with joy.
Tomorrow's Mother's Day. My mom started
our company. She's not here with us, but
um to know that
that other people believe in the company
as much as I do
is uh is profoundly powerful and an ode
and a testament to my mom's legacy. And
now I have an opportunity to to
implement what Alex has shared with me
today. And now I have the actual
strategy to scale.
>> [music]
>> All right. And so that was this episode
of Scale or Fail. Stay tuned for the
next one as they all compete for
$100,000 [music] in a year of working on
scaling.